so moin leute also moin das kann man im prinzipiel eben auch sagen auch wenn es die uhrzeit
nicht ganz her gibt late night stream die habe für meine verhältnisse schon ich zeige
euch immer den desktop weil ich weiß ihr mögt meinen desktop also oder sieht nur so aus
weil ich immer irgendwelche komischen images irgendwo hin ja heute gucken wir uns mal weiter
die essential wishlist studio code extensions an und als ich mir da vorhin darüber gedanken
gemacht habe ich habe es eben rum gebastelt wieder an so einem kleinen esp und habe ich
mir gedacht sehr müsste es eigentlich mal weiter gucken und bei der gelingen hat es
mir aufgefallen dass ich dass es schon komisch ist wie sich das editor mäßig alles entwickelt
hat ne also nicko dankeschön acht monate das ist ja fast schon aktuell wenn man mal hier
auf github guckt wie es code hat fragt mich nicht 50 150.000 sterne oder was auch immer
auf was weiß ich 100 2000 also auf jeden fall auf jeden fall heftiges zeug allerdings was
man daran witzigerweise auch sieht ist 120.000 sterne da müssen wir uns mal wieder also da
erkennt man mal wieder wie nische wir eigentlich sind weil das kann man so ein bisschen mit
subscriber vergleichen auf youtube her von so einem projekt und eines der größten projekte
auf der welt hat 120.000 sterne also sprich da das heißt das hat jeder zweite youtube
stell ja mittlerweile fast schon also da sieht man mal das ist man ist da man ist da schon
man gehört dazu zum kleinen prozentsatz die sowas benutzen bzw. die auch vielleicht ein
bisschen programmieren können oder so oder die das überhaupt interessiert ja und und
ich habe mir gedacht irgendwie ist es komisch wie sich das mit dem editor zeug entwickelt
hat ich mache übrigens von meiner vm an weil wir brauchen jetzt gleich die vm ja ich stare
auch nicht viel aber ich sage auf youtube auch nicht viel also das geht das nimmt sich
nicht viel das gibt es gibt es kommt doch gleich heraus zumindest bei meinem sub verhalten
zumindest wie sich das wie sich das ganze entwickelt hat ich weiß nicht wie es bei
euch aussieht aber es ist schon auf der einen seite ist es komisch und auf der anderen seite
ist es eigentlich offensichtlich dass es sich ein javascript editor durchgesetzt hat letztendlich
gibt es wenn du wenn du mal alle programmierer so nimmst die so auf der welt gibt ein riesen
großer teil davon ist javascript programmierer und der rest verteilt sich so aber ein ganz
großer teil ist frontend javascript webentwicklungs kram also frontend webentwicklung das heißt
es wundert mich nicht was erklär bitte wie du mit vias code für esp esp 32 jetzt naja
gut auf dem esp 32 läuft vias code noch nicht also oder was das wäre jetzt ja so war jetzt
immer noch nicht oder was war es was anderes oder wenn sie mit der sachen uploaden kann
kann ich dir zeigen das ist einfach naja zumindest wenn wenn ich mir so überlege wie sich das
ganze entwickelt hat als entwicklungsumgebung das ist einfach da zeige ich musste dir einfach
das hier angucken hier das ist alles was du machen musst mehr musst du legit nicht machen
das war es also wirklich kein witz mehr musst du nicht machen dann legst du ein neues projekt
an da drin das siehst du dann auf der startseite und dann kannst du dich austoben es ist überhaupt
kein ding also für ein für die einfachkeit halber ist platformer mit abstand das beste
hier die sind natürlich ein bisschen hinten dran also allgemein sind die sind so halt so
zusatz sachen immer ein bisschen hinten dran also zum beispiel wenn man jetzt sagt hey
ich möchte jetzt das ganz neueste hersteller framework verwenden am besten den master branch
den sie auf git haben dann läuft das da drin nicht so gut besser gesagt gar nicht aber
nachdem expressive also der hersteller vom esp 32 mit ihrem arduino mit ihre arduino implementiere
implementierung eh immer ein paar versionen hinten dran ist dann nimmt sich das wieder
nicht viel wenn ausgabe nicht ne noch nicht ich habe gesehen sie wird bis december support
und ich warte wieder bis bis auf den bis oft bis bis zum 8 december dann muss ich upgraden
ja wie gesagt mehr musst du nicht machen aber nochmal nochmal kurz bevor ich jetzt
anfangen mit mit den extensions also wie sich das editor mäßig entwickeln ist schon lustig
na früher also ich rede jetzt nicht von von prehistorischer zeit wo leute kommen nur
command line mit single zeilen edit gemacht haben oder sowas ja also so als ich richtig
angefangen habe als ich damals dort nicht gelernt habe das war also ich habe damals
ein bisschen in pyson buch gekauft und irgendwann mal mit dotnet framework 2 null war das glaube
ich ganz neu 2002 oder so angefangen da hast du unter windows eigentlich zwei sachen gehabt
du hast entweder die leute gehabt die am studio verwendet für nahezu alles damals gab es
auch so viele studio an uns für ruby für sonst was wir ach du scheiß was ist denn jetzt
los huge danke patrick wie viel fünf stück excellent subscriptions hier eigentlich für
die ganzen subs hier wir hatten was gekriegt i gamble null der hat glück der hat es hatte
hatte nicht letzten monat schon eins gekriegt hat ich weiß ich kann es nicht nach hat er
nicht letzten monat er hatte glaube ich echt glück autum musli freak der benn 09 und rin
dorbrot alles klar ja du hast letztes mal schon eingekriegt echter name liegt null ja
das ist ja mein echter namens übrigens tatsächlich max wer hätte das gedacht da es wieder patrick
patrick heißt so vor zwei monaten sagt twitch ach so ja vor zwei monaten icy fünf monate
dankeschön mit hier oh man muss den ramen ausblenden so ich komme ich komme ja gar nicht
dazu also da haben die leute dann rum gebastelt mit studio oder damals hatten die auch alle
notepad plus plus das war damals unter windows auch voll angesagt vor allem leute die irgendwie
pausen zeug unter windows gebastelt haben ganz fanden sie ganz toll zu damals das passt
ja ungefähr von der zeit her also und dann kam irgendwann kam die mech user und hatten
textmate falls jemand von euch noch textmate kennt irgendwann kam dann textmate und als
textmate dann aufgekommen ist haben alle gemerkt dass es gar nicht so übel ist achja die frontend
leute haben dreamweaver und so komisches gedöns verwendet falls kennt noch jemand dreamweaver
macromedia ist das ding das hat das damals die die was ist denn hier los gerade glocks hd ich
dachte das bimmel die ganze zeit schon vom letzten mal noch fünf stück wieder subscription
dankeschön für die subs wer kriegt diesmal was choose my name captain peng dams zwei verdient
die sehe ich oft hier so wen haben wir sonst noch den pfipps 2 habe ich jetzt auch auf das gesehen und
bambi capello auch am stat pc lustig den habe ich auch schon öfters hier gesehen dass sie die
abos aber gut verteilt der hype train auf stufe 4 was ist denn jetzt los
ja ja ja ja ja da läuft es aber das gem train läuft auf stufe 4 ja denn sie betrain
bald ist wieder september ihr hättet warten sollen leute ab morgen ab morgen ist das
ab und billiger aber ok also weil ich krieg auch nicht mehr kohle twitch kriegt jetzt einfach mehr
geld twitch freut sich bestimmt sebaro ai was ist denn hier fünf stück noch mal
eigentlich schön sehbaro exzellent wahrlich exquisite jetzt wir haben was gekriegt leckow
ich spreche das jedes mal anders aus ein bisschen leckow stufe 1 der hook herz 93 warte mich alle
hier schon öfters gesehen wir haben es verdient der titan toaster 69 habe ich auch schon auf das
gesehen mittlerweile kennt man die leute halbwegs geht mir auf youtube auch so oder ging mir so
lüku ok ging mir auf youtube auch so irgendwann kann man seit die üblichen verdächtigen ja
immer am anfang vom stream giften dann sind nicht so viele randoms da ich sehe schon die
gini stress ausgetauscht massive brain stress zumindest um jetzt mal das fertig zu erzählen
was ich erzählen wollte irgendwann haben die leute auf mac dann angefangen text made zu verwenden
und dann haben alle gesehen or text made das ist ja cool ich mein eigentlich war text made so im
nachhinein betrachtet jetzt nichts ultra geiles aber es war halt ein ordentlicher editor der klein
war schnell war da steams hatte syntax highlighting gescheit hatte ein bisschen erweiterbar war also
eigentlich wunderbar macros alles mögliche so und daraufhin hat dann irgendwer gesagt aber
wir machen es so bleibt text und dann hat jeder irgendwie so bleibt text verwendet
gibt es eigentlich wieder baut für view time nie könnte man programmieren ja
bitte einmal um und zu ja moment wo habe ich es denn wo ist es denn hier ich habe sieben
habe ich noch was übersehen ne oder hast du eigentlich noch alte projekte von 10 15 jahren
von c sharp wäre aber oh nee glaub nicht da kam ich nichts gescheites raus am anfang ich
müsste noch ich müsste noch ein ganz altes von 2000 2002 oder so python projekt aber mini
mini projekt haben wo ich versucht habe eines meiner ersten python skripte wo ich versucht
habe irgendwelche mail adressen zu filtern und ihr wisst dass das einfacher aussieht als es
letztendlich ist das müsste ich nämlich aus dem grund noch haben weil ich das damals per mail
geschickt habe zu einer bewerbung dazu also wenn ich glück haben ist ich das noch haben doch
ich habe noch ach nee glaub nicht zeigt das mal das muss ich erst mal raussuchen vielleicht habe
ich auch doch noch ein bisschen alles dort netz zeug mich rumgegimmt habe zumindest fertig um
das ganz ganz schnell mal abzuschließen hier dann hat god und die welt so bleiben text verwendet
und ab dann ging eigentlich so so die ersten editor wars geschichten los ich meine wir reden
jetzt mal nicht von wim versus emax was schon seit 19 frag mich 85 oder so ein thema ist aber
dann haben die leute auf einmal angefangen ihren wim aufzumotzen die andere haben angefangen in
sublime text abzukreieren und und sonst was dann hat jeder die anderen haben spacemax emax gemacht
oder so was es gab dann ganz viele verschiedene dinge und jeder hat das ding ausgebaut bis zum
geht nicht mehr und quasi gezeigt wer den geileren editor hat so da kam dann irgendwann noch dieses
ganze andere zeug auf da kam die jetbrains dinger langsam die auch viele verwendet haben das das
ist ja auch noch nicht alles so ewig dass das jetbrains acht verschiedene idees hat oder so was
ja und dann so langsam aber sicher kamen die ganzen java script editors auf wir haben
sich atom zu verdanken dass es den kram überhaupt gibt
prakets prakets gab prakets war eine sache an prakets war richtig gut für die damalige
zeit das war nämlich das live editieren von html seiten prakets ist glaube ich immer noch
wird immer noch na nicht mehr nicht mehr so wirklich na schon ein bisschen her ist eigentlich ist
eigentlich mehr oder weniger dead und das letzte release 6 april geht ja sogar was meck und
windows what the fuck warum ja ist ziemlich dead ja prakets aber prakets war ganz cool mit
live editing von html also da kannst du quasi im editor sagen wir eine farbe anpassen und dann
hat sich das live geupdatet oder der scam train hat reingeholt ist durchgefahren drübergefahren
ich habe diese ganzen emotes glaube noch nie verwendet aber die sehen sogar tatsächlich
aus so und ja wie gesagt atom haben wir das zu verdanken dass die haben damit angefangen
komodo komodo die leute früher auch verwendet atom hat damal hat damit angefangen elektron
haben wir atom zu verdanken und github haben wir atom zu verdanken also quasi ist github
schuld an elektron und ganz viel müll und ab da hat sich damals haben wir das noch voll ausgelacht
das weiß ich noch aber habt ihr gesehen github hat ein editor rausgebracht javascript und da
haben wir uns richtig lustig gemacht dass atom am anfang keine dateien öffnen konnte die größer
als zwei mb groß waren oder 2k oder 2kb ultra klein auf jeden fall für den text editor das
hat aber meistens gereicht und atom war lahm as fuck aber atom hat ziemlich fad aufgenommen genauso
wie auch prakets aber atom hauptsächlich und da haben dann viele gesagt ach guck mal es ist ja
eigentlich cool wenn man einen editor mit javascript erweitern kann ich schiebe das alles ein
bisschen darauf dass so bleiben text es verschissen hat ordentlich neuerungen zu bringen und quasi
vier jahre in tiefschlaf gegangen ist mit ihrem editor weil so bleiben hatte die userbase so bleiben
hatte die grundlagen und die die plug in geschichten die haben leider zu spät zu wenig an plug in
support gebracht du konntest ja lange zeit mit plugins gar nicht alles machen oder immer noch
nicht alles machen und daraufhin kamen die ganzen javascript editors und die leute haben gesehen
fack guck mal man kann den editor jetzt total easy total easy erweitern und irgendwann kam dann
microsoft und hat gesagt ok wir machen jetzt atom in nicht ganz so langsam und dann gab's
visual studio code und seit visual studio code am start ist spätestens seit microsoft da jetzt
auch noch anfängt mit github rum zu machen ist das ding durch die decke gegangen ich glaube visual
studio code dürfte mittlerweile der mit abschon am meisten verwendete editor sein wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich also wenn man rein auf wie oft hat man welchen editor am tag auf dann ist wahrscheinlich
wim auch noch ähnlich häufig offen weil leute machen halt wenn sie auf der kommando seite sind
stellen mal den wim auf dem server auf und zwei sachen zu editieren aber das dürfte ganz weit
vorne sein ja wie es code und wie es code und wie du denkst das andere wie das heißt das ist ja
im prinzip alles mehr oder weniger das gleiche es fehlen bloß ein paar tracking sachen so war
deine berufsschule auch so pepega massif pepega so muss man kurz fragen questions mehr angucken
im chat kennt das noch jemand hier macromedia dream wie wir da kommt man richtig gut an den
älteren editieren für die damalige zeit naja also matze 20 90 fragt wie bist du eigentlich zum
programmieren gekommen beziehungsweise dich für informatik zu interessieren vm kriegt ich mal ab
also ich bin also wie ich angefangen habe zu programmieren das weiß ich also ich kann
mich an die ursprüngliche sache nicht erinnern aber es war garantiert sowas dass ich irgendwas
basteln wollte was es nicht gab ich glaube ich wollte automatisch email anhänge von meinen
emails absplitten oder irgendwie sowas und das habe ich damals in pearl probiert und pearl war
im moment nicht nicht nicht pains champ war das und das hat nicht richtig funktioniert und ich
glaube damals habe ich mir gedacht ok was ist gerade so angesagt da waren ruby und pyson und
habe ich mir gedacht ruby vor den komischen japaner nehmen wir nicht wir nehmen pyson weil
das damals schon 2002 oder so der neueste shit war und jetzt immer noch irgendwie und dann habe
ich festgestellt da habe ich mir ein pyson buch gekauft ich kann mal gucken ob ich noch
finde welches das war das fand ich eigentlich ganz gut kann man bei amazon alte meine bestellung
kann man bei amazon bestellung suchen von 2000 irgendwie sowas 2002 oder so gab es da überhaupt
schon amazon habe ich das überhaupt auf amazon gekauft ist die frage wahrscheinlich noch nicht
mal kannst du mal vollknicken ich habe 2006 und du ein duden gekauft aber das denn ein duden
so ein schwachsinn ich weiß nicht mehr so jetzt habe ich ein pyson buch gekauft und hab ich
festgestellt das ist nicht so meins und dann habe ich geguckt und habe festgestellt aha
wishlist studio express dotnet sie scharpe express damals und dann habe ich das ausprobiert und
seitdem muss ich sagen es ist ja nicht oft es ist ja gar nicht so oft würde ich sagen dass man bei
der einstehung wobei ich bin ja auch nicht bei der einstiegssprache geblieben ja pyson habe ich
ganz ganz relativ schnell dann über bord geschmissen weil ich eben weil ich ein bisschen windows gui
machen wollte und dann habe ich angefangen mit dotnet und seitdem muss ich sagen ist dotnet immer
mal meine lieblingssprache also sie scharpe meine lieblingssprache geblieben und wie ich
angefangen habe mich generell für so technikram zu interessieren kann ich dir echt nicht sagen
es hat mich schon immer interessiert streamforscher cloud vps mit wire guard warum soll ich es in der
cloud machen der cloud ist also in der cloud ist ja grad war ja gart und ein pijol jetzt nicht
nicht so so geil oder so vorzu oder meinst du dass du dir dann mobil als dns einstellen kannst ja
weiß ich nicht ob das so muss ich mal überlegen hast du da neues video schon in kasten was für
ein headset kannst du empfehlen was nicht nach zwei tagen gefühlt kaputt geht bayerdynamics
mx 300 so ok kennst du cute ja ist das einzig sinnvolle cross platform gui framework was nicht
elektron ist und der chat kennt das auch war das schon python 2 ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung
ich glaube schon 22 oder sowas ich glaube irgendein irgendein 22er war das mit dem ich
angefangen habe was ein abschlussprojekt in pearl programmiert ohje dazu muss man
entweder sehr mutig sein oder massive big brain oder nicht wissen worauf man sich einlässt eins
von beiden ich bin schon seit amazon gibt was kennst du ne kenne ich nicht fau mysterious
abonniert twitch prime dankeschön für den sub moment ich finde meine emails ich big brain
subscription wieder hier flow 96 sagt als ich angefangen habe zu programmieren das war so
lächerlich damals ich kannte noch keine daten über haben einfach jeden zwischengespeicherten
wert als label auf die oberfläche geklappt ja so gedürnt hat am anfang jeder gemacht ohne
richtigen namen einfach nur unsichtbar gemacht sprache vb es gibt leute die sind da heute nicht
rüber rausgekommen du hast gesagt dass du vor deiner physik ausbildung gemacht hast ja habe
ich weiß ich nicht aber ich habe das mal erzählt habe ich habe tatsächlich versucht so ein
stonks beruf zu lernen haben festgestellt es sagt wie x widgets hör mal auf du kennst
bestimmt auch mqtt klar dokter jack twitch prime excellent subscription huge dankeschön
bist du hast noch gar nichts verpasst ich bin jetzt gerade mit dem chat durch kobold
streben an weihnachten programmierlehrer war absolut geiler typ ja das ist gut wenn
du leute hast damals war es glaube ich auch so wenn es das gegeben hat dann war das von
lehrern dies interessiert hat so ich zeige euch jetzt bevor wir bevor wir nach extensions
kommen ich zeige euch jetzt mal meine einzige wirkliche must have extension wenn man html
zeug macht ich mache zwar nicht permanent html zeug aber keiner kommt heute an frontend
sachen vorbei genau die meisten werden es wahrscheinlich schon kennen das hier was
das macht ist folgendes ich erzähle das nicht ich zeige euch das einfach oder tippe hat
kein bock mehr auch gut klaus also wenn ihr ein bisschen html zeug machen müsst das meist
die bei den meisten leuten sieht das so aus aber wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt mal
kurz hier diese diese seite auf ja so einmal kurz den firefox auf und dann gehen wir mal
wo liegt die seite überhaupt ach du scheiße wie wie öffne ich die überhaupt hier so
ne okay index html ne wie geht das ach keck we heißt das ding so auf der seite steht
nicht nicht drauf so die meisten leute wenn die das machen machen dann sowas die probieren
das dann hier aus sagen hallo speichern neu laden aha 123 speichern neu laden welche die
besonders advanced sind die schaffen das ja platformer ja ist das das beste wenn man sowas
machen so manche sind dann besonders big brain schon und machen dann quasi safe und haben
dann so einen so einen tiling window manager und können dann hier f5 drücken so so mit
nur mit tastatur ohne ohne maus so das gibt noch verschiedene zwischenstufen und es gibt
auch ein paar andere erweitere mit dem man das machen kann es gab früher mal live reload
und sowas aber die einfachste variante ist tatsächlich die hier man installiert das
live live server plugin das da und dann sagt man einfach nur open with live server so man
geht in den browser auf und jetzt passt mal auf jetzt tippe ich hier cute chat und speichere
beim reload so muss das sein sag reload seht ihr das ist wenn man hier unten nachguckt
in der konsole sieht man auch dass der irgendwelche normalerweise steht es drin dass der irgendwelche
extensions lädt ne macht er nicht ok merkwürdig aber das ist wirklich eines der besten extensions
ist nicht black block block quote also seht ihr ich kann den ganzen mist hier zack zack
zack zack speichern da ist es das ist wirklich gut das ist wirklich gut diese extension es
geht jetzt nicht so drunter die webseite schön machen sag mal kennt einer mal eine frage
an euch kennt einer ein gutes mir fällt schwer es css framework zu nennen kennt jemand was
richtig schönes kleines an css wo bisschen css vordefiniert ist dass die seiten nicht
ganz so hässlich aussehen also irgendwas am besten unter 10 kilobyte nein was kleines
ich mein was kleines was was wirklich kleines also sprich was ich auch für eine webseite
von einem esp 32 nehmen kann so irgendwas irgendwas keine 10 kilobyte oder sowas einfach
was nur ein paar sachen vordefiniert hat dass es nicht so nervig ist css tailwind ne tailwind
muss man zu viel selbst machen jammel was zum geil was jammel damit zu tun was ist das
denn css reset von 2011 das sieht ja oldschool aus bulma ja das ist alles so groß ich brauche
irgendwas richtig kleines am besten so ein classless ding wo du einfach nur html schreibst
und style automatisch haben wir hier base 7 kilobyte was ist 7 kilobyte sowas hier wobei
ich sagen muss dass ich die alle nicht so schön finden die sehen alle ein bisschen kacke aus
mein das hier finde ich sieht noch halbwegs das geht noch zumal es auch einen dark theme
hat aber es ist aber auch nur fünf kilobyte ich habe noch nichts schönes gefunden mini
css mini css oh das ist archiviert das soll man nicht mal verwenden auf weiß mit kann
mir eigentlich egal sein so gibt es da auch irgendwie mal so eine so ein beispiel sei
ach so was hier das ist gar nicht so das gefällt mir das ist eigentlich ganz hübsch und es
muss klein sein das gucken wir gleich mal ob das klein ist cdn hier wie groß ist denn
das ganze was zum teufel wie kriege ich das jetzt runtergeladen hier irgendwo releases
oder so source mini what the fuck ist das da ist das da mini mini fire wings dist aber
dist ist da nicht ah doch dist ist da mini dark css mini dark min ok gucken wir mal wie
groß das ist also moment falsch einmal wie gätten viel zu groß viel zu groß na gut wenn
man das ding geht zippt geht zipp mini ah also ich hätte es gerne bisschen kleiner
moment stimmt ich habe ich habe ich habe mist ich habe mist runtergeladen ich habe mist
runtergeladen das hier muss runterladen kein que ich habe es ich habe es falsche runtergeladen
ich habe die ganze github seite gerade runtergeladen ok kommen wir mal jetzt aber hups ah da kommen
wir da kommen wir schon eher in die richtung so und das ganze jetzt geht zippt ja ja 8,1
kilobyte geht zippt damit kann man doch arbeiten wie gesagt ich habe hier die partitionierung
vom esp 32 umgestellt also sprich ich habe jetzt nur irgendwie 400 kb oder 350 kb oder
irgendwie sowas flash für dateien noch übrig dann kann ich den rest vollkleistern mit sachen
die es programmieren angenehmer machen zum beispiel sowas hier das braucht auch ein bisschen
speicherplatz dass man nicht komisches printf machen muss sondern die sachen ordentlich
formatieren kann was 704 kilobyte insgesamt ist ach man 704 ich habe das noch mal ich
habe es anders partitioniert ich habe das off stream noch mal anders partitioniert und
ich glaube da war es dann ein bisschen weniger ich habe so gemacht dass das die schriftarten
gut drauf passen und ein bisschen platz für eine webseite ist übrigens zeige euch mal
was ich gebastelt habe ich schließe mal kurz das bord an aber ohne dass wir jetzt die ide
aufmachen ich zeige euch nur mal kurz was weil das problem war ja dass ich keine logs
bekomme über die webseite beziehungsweise keine logs auslesen kann über wlan ich habe
jetzt was ganz ganz billiges gemacht und zwar wenn man jetzt hier macht karl minus k hier
wenn man sich darauf jetzt connectet werdet ihr sehen ah moment logs das nicht logs werdet
ihr sehen der lässt einfach den socket den socket den socket auf und schiebt permanent
die aktuellen logs über die html verbindung das ist glaube ich die billigste art und weise
wie man remote loggen kann jetzt kriege ich quasi logs von meinem ich habe jetzt ein
bisschen testtext die logs von meinem sp2 als die serielle ausgabe von einem sp 32 schiebe
ich quasi über den htm tcp socket rüber also es ist eigentlich ist das html also über
ssh da noch und so wenn es einfach einfach logs rüber gedammt was halt ganz praktisch
ist weil das eines der probleme ist wenn man den sp 32 eben was machen will und der nicht
am rechner ist dann kann man keine logs sehen von der seriellen schrittstelle und so geht
das jetzt ich kann euch leider den code nicht zeigen weil das habe ich drüben in anderen
vm so ich mache wieder raus so kommen wir mal zum visual studio codes dinger also wir
haben jetzt hier eine ex-excellent webseite gebastelt also besser besser besser kann man
sogar mal machen wir müssen jetzt noch mal ganz eine sache ist ist ist unglaublich unglaublich
wichtig dass wir noch das das muss man noch größer machen font size 30 pixel bam so
ist das und hier font family ja ne das so ja ja ex-excellent also besser besser kann
man die webseite gar nicht mehr gestalten also die diese extension ist dafür wirklich
wunderbar ihr habt gesehen ich habe nix refreshed ich habe einfach nur hier editiert gespeichert
und da refreshed automatisch das ist top wenn man die bisschen advancedere variante davon
ist hack font kann ich machen aber das nämlich normalerweise ungern auf der webseite weil
es hat keiner installiert die bisschen advancedere variante ist wenn man sowas wie view jr
view js macht dass man dann den projektgenerator verwendet und der hat sowas ähnliches schon
drin aber für einfache html sein oder ohne irgendwas ist das hier wirklich die beste
extension ist so ziemlich die einzige must have sache wie sieht es mit fehlermeldungen
aus also alles alles was ich auf also alles was ich auch seriell logge wobei ne das stimmt
nicht ganz also ich muss es loggen also sprich wenn das irgendwie intern gelockt wird von
den modulen dann nicht weil da komme ich nicht so ohne weiteres dran aber meine sache reichen
mir auch das wäre auch noch mal eine frage wie man das machen könnte das an der komplette
log da müsste man irgendwie den stint den serial buffer irgendwie abgreifen oder so
oder serial neu die feier keine ahnung ach so wenn ich fehler im html habe das ist kein
das ist kein ding also wenn ich fehler html habe dann refresh die seite trotzdem das ist
dem egal aber dann geht es halt geht die seite halt nicht das ist dem das ist dem vollkommen
egal ob das kaputt ist oder nicht so also das wie gesagt must have absolute must have
erweiterung was ich letztens gefunden habe was ich aber nicht gut finde muss ich gleich
sagen ist auch als an sich eine richtig coole erweiterung aber ich finde sie nicht gut
man sieht ja ich bin auch nicht der einzige der hatte der hatte eine echt gute idee der
typ hier der hatte eine echt gute idee ich zeige euch mal hier repos das repo auf github
hat auch ordentlich viel sterne der hat quasi einen browser in also einen richtigen browser
eingebunden in visual studio code also wenn man das jetzt mal sich auf der auf der zunge
zergehen lässt dann ist es ein browser in einem browser eingebunden weil visual studio code
ist ja eigentlich nur ein browser das ist halt irgendwie monark s das ist halt ein browser
in einem browser wenn man so will und warum ich es nicht warum ich es nicht mag kann
ich euch gleich zeigen weil es leckt das ist chromeception ja so also öffnen wir irgendwie
was hier live preview ne ne wie war das review ja so ihr seht schon wie das leckt ne seht
ihr wie das leckt das ist blurry und laggy as fuck also das kann man wirklich nicht ordentlich
verwenden wirklich nett kannst du den browser github codes du kannst in den browser theoretisch
alles öffnen aber guckt mal wie das leckt und und und wie wie blurry das ganze ist das
ist un un unnutzbar alter richte das mal an ganda falls asleep extra wie das leckt nee
muss zu machen also das ist eine coole eine coole idee für den plugin aber es funktioniert
nicht es ist leider leider zu laggy das ist übrigens bei design der kann da nichts machen
weil er hat nen embedded chromium da drin noch laufen und von dem zieht er sich über
die api vom chrome nen screenshot von der webseite und blendet den da ein also der überträgt
quasi pngs von von hätte von einem headless chrome screenshotte da die webseite und überträgt
die png also es ist big brain aber es ist langsam und das ganze in visual studio code
embedded also sprich den browser in den browser der gestreamt wird über png bilder willkommen
in 2020 er nee das ist uns wichtig auf der einen seite ist poggers auf der anderen seite
ist es ziemlich zum auseinander laufen einfach mehr screenshots mal die die die github issues
sind voll davon dass das ding abkackt in visual studio mit mit reißt nee so also was gibt
es was sind sonst noch für sachen die hier empfohlen werden ich habe hier mal die sachen
vom letzten mal aufgemacht das letzte mal hatten wir noch irgendwie so eine liste da
sind wir aber durch gewesen glaube ich ich glaube das hatten wir das letzte mal durch
gewusstet wim emulation damit kann ich in visual studio code nix anfangen so sehr ich
will mark für mal kurz sachen komando zeilen mäßig editieren ich bin wenn ich visual
studio aufbinde ich nicht im modus da bin ich im maus clicker modus was aber auch einfach
daran liegt dass man wenn man irgendwas programmiert permanent den browser wechseln muss um irgendwas
zu suchen also programmieren hat ja nichts mit texte texte tippen zu tun wenn man realistisch
ist programmieren hat was mit google suchen zu tun wie geht es dann jetzt eigentlich also
keine ahnung mit welchen parametern müssen da rein was darf ich da nicht reinstecken
was wie was bekomme ich also im prinzip ist 90 prozent von programmieren google suche
und 10 prozent problem und 9 prozent denken problemlos ein prozent tippen so deswegen
kann ich die argumentation von den hardcore wim usern auch nicht verstehen die sagen ich
benutze wim weil die maus ist der teufel und und ich möchte meine finger immer auf
der home row und solche dinger denn die sache ist die du brauchst eh permanent die maus
für den browser weil man kann den browser nicht gescheit über shortcuts bedienen geht
einfach nicht es gibt ein paar gute browser addons die man wo man dann beispielsweise
hier an links einblenden kann das ist für die tastatursteuerung ganz nett da drückt
man zum beispiel eine tast oder so space oder sowas und dann blendet er hier an jedem link
zahlen eine wenn ich die zahltrücke öffne den link das ist eigentlich ganz nett aber
ist du kannst du kannst den browser nicht gescheit bedienen über das funktioniert einfach nicht
genau so also schauen wir mal was haben die sonst noch hier zu bieten code quality mein
guter wie gesagt dokumentiert sich selbst brauchen wir nicht code quality was was kommt
als nächstes irgendwie unit test schreiben oder was so was machen wir hier nicht links
auch top browser die meisten hardcore wimmer nutzen das auch nicht für webdesign für
sondern für application die würde ich ja gebe ich dir recht wahrscheinlich ist das
wirklich so aber es war mal eine zeit bei den ganzen hipster web app leuten war wim
voll hoch im kurs ich kann mich noch an ruby konferenz talks erinnern wo sie da gestanden
haben und und wim plugins gezeigt haben ich muss aber echt sagen also ich gucke mir öfters
ich gucke mir relativ viele konferenz talks an ja ich habe mir sogar letzter zeit wieder
ein paar z plus plus konferenz talks angeguckt um mich dann jedes mal zu fragen wie wo die
geistig irgendwo falsch abgebogen sind die leute da die die z plus plus standard machen
aber paar sachen sind teilweise doch ganz interessant und ich kann mich aber noch an
einen vortrag erinnern über den muss ich heute immer noch lachen das war ist schon
ewig her das war die zeit wo ruby und rails voll angesagt war weil sich da überhaupt
noch jemand dran erinnern kann das war mal der halb schlechthin 2008 oder so das ist
ja überhaupt nicht mehr überhaupt nicht mal angesagt mittlerweile ist ruby und rails ja
evolving das ist auch ein schöner ausdruck ruby ja so und das war angesagt und da habe
ich nen webcast konferenz talk von einem gesehen so einer der ober so einer der ober ruby gurus
war das also nicht der matz sondern in den selbstander ober ruby gurus mach ich denn
hier jetzt zumindest wisst ihr was der gesagt hat der hat sich drüber ausgelassen so nach
dem motto was alles aus seiner sicht auch so ein wort das mag ich überhaupt nicht in
die code smells sind also kurz also also code der stinkt quasi also oder was so aussieht
wie wir also total beknackt also irgendwas was halt nicht so ordentlich ist auf gut deutsch
ja toxi acht monate dankeschön so und zumindest hat er ernsthaft behauptet dieser ruby guru
in einem konferenz talk hat er gesagt ok wenn ihr funktionen und methoden programmiert
in ruby oder generell für web anwenden im allgemeinen allgemein hat er das gesagt dann
muss man darauf achten dass die funktionen nicht so lang werden so weit so gut hey da
gebe ich ihm voll und ganz rechts und dann sagt er dann hat man den guten eindruck den
ich von ihm hat direkt wird zunichte gemacht dann hat er gemeint was was denn das publikum
meint ab wann für ihn eine methode zu lang ist ab wann die smelt und dann hat er so rhetorisch
gewartet der chat ist gar nicht so verkehrt und er hat wirklich gesagt mehr als eine zeile
habe ich komplett am verstanden von dem typ gezweifelt willst du dein komplettes program aus
ein zeiler methoden programmieren oder was wo machst du die logik rein irgendwo musst
du noch die loge kannst du nicht mit von mit die dich von methoden aufruf zu betonen aufruf
hangeln was hast denn dann für eine tiefe an calls 20.000 oder was oder man schreibt
einfach mit kommen alles in eine zeile ja man darf nicht alles für bar münze nehmen
was die leute in konferenztalks erzählen ich habe letztens in c++ konferenztalk geguckt
und das war hat sogar einen weiblichen speaker kommt gerade bei c++ konferenzen nicht so
häufig vor und die hat irgendwie was erzählt dass da muss ich da muss ich auch mal hart
kecken als ich das gehört habe hat erzählt dass das standard komitee schon an alle nahezu
alle nur erdenklichen sachen gedacht hat die man so braucht aber ich bin halt reden wir
von der gleichen programmier sprache ja also die gleiche programmier sprache die es nicht
für möglich hält string to upper oder to lower einzubauen die haben man alles gedacht
ja ist das so musstest du auf der arbeit schon mal mit c++ arbeiten nein musste ich nicht
und zum glück es gibt to upper und to lower in der standard aber auf welche art und weise
ist lächerlich standard to upper standard to lower und dann den string inter als also
wer sich den plötzlich ausgedacht hat so hey max kannst du vielleicht ein paar youtube
kanäle empfehlen bei denen man programmieren lernen kann nein nein leider nicht weil so
wirklich basic sachen gucke ich mir nicht mehr an ich kriege da kriege ich zum glück
mittlerweile halbwegs hinten die basics die basics ja es gibt viele gute channels die
man gucken kann wenn man zu weiterführen und sagt also wirklich kann ich dir jetzt echt
nicht sagen also was ich mache wenn ich irgendwas neues zum beispiel als ich als ich go mir
angeguckt habe für diese web rtc webcam software die erste version war ja eine mischung aus
go und c und jetzt ist es eine mischung aus c sharp und leider go weil ich nicht drum
rumkomme und was ich da gemacht habe ist ich habe mal auf youtube geguckt ich habe die
offiziellen guides mal durchgescrollt und ganz ehrlich ich habe einfach angefangen und mich
an fehler meldungen lang gehangelt da kommt man da kommt man ganz gut bei weg hashtag
schwul was was möchtest du uns sagen ist das irgendwas was ich nicht kenne oder willst
du nerven das oder ist es irgendwie go ist auch ganz ok go ist ok ja go ist ist an manchen
stellen ein bisschen fragwürdig warum sie sachen nicht machen go ist eine sprache wo
die jahre lang behaupten dass es unsinnig wäre was andere sprachen haben zum beispiel
so was wie generics und dann fällt ihnen später also oder hast du auch nicht verkehrt das
ist so das das ist so die die das ist so die gole die die go taktik ich mein dass du nicht
mal ordentliche ordentliche maps in go typ sichermachen kannst und so also egal aber
go ist im vergleich zu c++ wahre wohltat ja ich habe ja heute ein bisschen html wieder
gemacht und ich muss sagen von dem ganzen c++ gefrickel da fanden javascript war sogar
erholsam ja russ russ ist auch ein bisschen ja russ ist ist zu big brain für 90 prozent
der leute russ ist zu advanced ich war da noch was geschrieben sebarro ist am bann hier
der cute mod schlägt zu russ ist ein one on one quickscope ja genau also die russ installation
ist easy einfach russ ab und russ installieren allerdings ist russ eine sprache die ist an
sich sehr gut durchdacht und auch relativ konsistent aber russ finde ich sieht halt trotzdem echt
hässlich aus mit 30 milliarden klammern ultra große eindrückungstiefe und und zwischendrin
spitzen klammern und irgendwelche also hübsch ist russ nicht auch wenn es gut durchdacht
ist es gibt auch gut durchdachte konsistenz konsistente man die nicht hübsch sind und
da ist russ russ russ github kommt bei irgendwas anders ihr wisst wovon ich rede aber wir machen
mit braun in den in den projekt wo ein bisschen was drinne steht so hallo na moment da ist
ja nur die feins drin ich brauche ein bisschen was längeres ich war okay ich bin allein
schon hier kann man es ungefähr erahnen dass es nicht so die allerschönste sache ist gibt
da vielleicht noch ein bisschen was längeres response response muss ein bisschen länger
sein aber versteht das nur aus die feins oder irgendwie zu der macht es der hat den ruby
talk gehört nicht mehr als eine zeile hier sowas sowas hier ist als schön ist es nicht
manchmal ja also es ist nicht so schlimm wie c++ ja aber gut lesbar also russ ist nicht
hübsch kann es sein dass es platform io für wisst wie es kodium nicht gibt das kann sein
wenn die reine open source sachen nur erlauben dann nicht weil die haben dependency auf die
microsoft c++ extension und die microsoft c++ extension hat dependency auf irgendein
closed source wishell studio c gedöns so schauen wir mal weiter was haben wir noch für plugins
zu bieten hier also ganze code quality sachen brauchen wir definitiv nicht unser code macht
erstens nie fehler und zweitens erklärt er sich komplett selbst ist ja ist ja normal da
brauchen wir das alles nicht könntest du eventuell eine i3 config teilen habe ich schon
habe ich mal hochgeladen vor fünf monaten als ich also wir haben im stream die vm neu
eingerichtet und dann habe ich die sachen hochgeladen hier guck mal wo ist er denn da
exzellent das ist fast die standard conflict mit ein bisschen klein klein kram
turbo console lock das haben wir schon das ist richtig gut die extension die extension
ist messer also wenn ich mal weiß was sie macht die ist wirklich gut wenn man sagt
ok ich habe hier ein bisschen javascript gedöns gebastelt kein amb plus plus keck
weh lull so ich habe ein bisschen javascript und jetzt will ich die backen und gucken was
da drin steht dann kann ich nämlich einfach sagen turbo ich habe vergessen wie es geht
wie ging das noch mal turbo display lock message genau und jetzt haben wir festgestellt
dass es verbugt ist jetzt haben wir es kaputt gemacht top zumindest kann man da wenn man
es richtig verwendet jetzt aber bin ich jetzt war ich das falsch what the fuck ging es nicht
so ah jetzt genau wie ging das noch mal muss ich b machen ach so genau das generiert für
ein javascript die back print statements das ist wirklich eine coole sache gewesen
habe ich jetzt oder habe ich das irgendwie verkehrt gemacht kann man dann beides jetzt
komisch zumindest das hat echt einen guten eindruck gemacht das haben wir haben wir uns
im letzten stream habe ich das gefunden und habe ich das behalte ich mal das macht einen
ganz guten eindruck wobei ich jetzt sagen muss irgendwie ist es kann ein bisschen am
rumspacken gehen hier weil vor allem man kann auch sagen man kann das ganze debug zeug auch
wieder wieder weg machen lassen und sowas was ist das für ein programm was denn das
hier das ist das ist visual studio code so also das hat einen ganz guten eindruck gemacht
error lens was macht das error lens turbocharged das ist auch so ein marketing bullshit wort
ach so man es wird es nee das geht mir auf den sack das brauche ich nicht sowas microsoft
edge chromium tool zu visual studio code ok jetzt wollen sie jetzt wollen sie das mehr
edge tools installiert was ist denn hier los ach so man kann da irgendwelche browsersachen
im add brauche man eigentlich auch nicht emoji sense brauche man nicht kann man unter windows
das dann nehmen oder oder jungs was anderes ai assist jetzt aber das haben wir doch alles
schon eingeguckt das haben wir uns doch alles schon angeschaut pass intellisense das fand
ich auch cool das hatten wir auch das haben wir auch ausprobiert pass pass irgendwas
dass der die dateinnahmen quasi einfügen kann autocomplete das war eigentlich ganz
nice advance new file man nicht heil utils ok das jetzt java script gedöns das nee da
komme ich leider nicht drum herum best extensions to do plus ich glaube to do plus hatten wir
noch nicht wir hatten ein paar andere to do sachen ach das da moment ich glaube das habe
ich sogar mal ausprobiert und das habe ich dann genau das das bringt mir nichts also
ich meine es ist auf der einen seite ganz cool weil es plaintext to do liste sind aber
auf der anderen seite eine to do liste ohne sync möglichkeiten die auch auf mobilen geräten
funktioniert bringt mir nix oder für was fändest du das live share live share als sie
das vorgestellt haben irgendwie auf der vorletzten bild oder so fand ich habe ich mir gedacht
wer braucht denn sowas was nutzt du dann für to do liste das hier mal gucken ob es hier
überhaupt was fehlt hat nee habe ich nicht das da nicht das da nicht angelina julie
das da verwende ich ich bin damit auch nicht so hundertprozentig glücklich weil es ist
halt elektron auf dem desktop und es ist jetzt auch auf tablets nicht so wahnsinnig geschwind
aber einen großen vorteil hat das es gibt es für windows linux mac ios und android also
es ist alles abgedeckt und es hat halt alles in diesem programm drinne also sprich du kannst
das zünden über irgendwie x beliebigen share ist vollkommen egal es hat einen guten web
klipper das wo man webseiten bookmarks und zeugs noch speichern kann und es hat notifications
für alle plattformen drin das ist eigentlich fast das wichtigste dass ich quasi eine to
do liste machen kann auf linux eintrag und das züngt und dann geht die notification
fünf minuten vorher auch auf meinem handy los das ist das einzige was es da open source
mäßig gibt was das so cross platform gut hinbekommt ja irgendein cloud dienst zu verwenden
microsoft to do oder evernote oder sonst was das geht natürlich auch aber wenn man selbst
hosten will ist finde ich das die beste variante ja und live share ist tatsächlich ganz gut
ich habe das belacht als das bei der auf der bild vorgestellt wurde das braucht doch keiner
und man kann sich doch immer noch die mark session scheren oder sonst was aber es ist
schon es ist schon schöner wenn man seinen kompletten gui editor scheren kann als einfach
nur das terminal also ist ziemlich gut habe ich jetzt schon ein paar mal verwendet gerade
in der zeit wo jetzt hier gehome office wird ist es tatsächlich sehr praktisch sehe ich
auch so exzellent speichert das dann nicht auch deine daten auf deren server ne das züngt
gar nicht das züngt nur wenn du es einstellst auf sachen von dir also du kannst sagen ja
sünke auf dropbox wenn du dropbox inszeniert hast aber du kannst auch mit zünken mit was
du willst wie findest du das plugin für visual studio code ich verwende in visual studio
code und in allen anderen gui editors keine keine plugins weil ich dann im kopf nicht
im modus bin im modus bin ich nur hier im modus bin ich nur hier ansonsten bin ich auch
wenn ich wirklich was ernsthaftes mache auch viel zu sehr beschäftigt zwischen browser
und editor hin und her zu wechseln mit der maus also ich sehe da den vorteil vom modus
nicht klar du kannst die ganze wim shortcuts verwenden du kannst ja irgendwie sowas machen
wie keine ahnung ci klammer ci quotes und sowas aber da denke ich in visual studio code
nicht dran ich bin nicht im modus icon theme haben wir schon da war ich tatsächlich überrascht
von dass es doch ganz nett ist ja icon theme sind sowas wo ich immer sage schwach sind
brauchst du nicht aber das ist wirklich ganz nett so also remote blablabla ja was macht
was von code runner what the fuck im moment sehe ich das richtig der typ macht werbung
für engländer hat er ein buch geschrieben dann werde das würde ich ja auch verstehen
ja wenn er ein buch geschrieben hat soll er doch werbung machen ist doch ist doch in
ordnung solange es keine ref links sind jetzt für andere sachen warum nicht soll er machen
ach genau das war die geschichte wo man einfach sachen visual studio ausführen kann da muss
ich ehrlich sagen da habe ich nicht verstanden warum da so viele leute verwenden ich meine
ich kann einfach einen terminal aufmachen oder ich kann das terminal hier unten verwenden
und so viele sachen die ich markieren kann und ausführen will habe ich im editor nicht
verstehen also da habe ich jetzt den sinn noch nicht ganz verstanden von was da dran
so so 4,7 millionen downloads ist die musik ja die musik macht wup wup wup ultra wup wup
hey das soll das soll eigentlich voll chill sein es hört sich halt grad nicht chill an
ich mache normalerweise solche sachen immer an weil halt nix passiert im hintergrund so
so man stehen geblieben was gibt paid extensions es gibt es gibt was ist das es gibt wirklich
paid extensions ah javascript gedöns ok jokka paid ja was denn jetzt moment ist es jetzt
könnte ich jetzt mal entscheiden
ach so das ist ein bisschen was wie jupiter oder sowas ja wenn man es braucht geht oder
wie es manche leute fälschlicherweise ausbremschen oh das ist cool
das ist gut weil man hat nicht immer wenn man was macht nen repo initialisiert
und man editiert man manchmal was ohne dass man ein git repo initialisiert hat oder das
gar committet und möchte irgendwas zurück und dann hat man hier ne history das ist eigentlich
ganz cool zeigt mal wie ist dann das rating zu
so sowas committet man doch auch nicht mit
das ist natürlich doof warum macht er das nicht in dort für studio code was man nicht
committet oder in irgendein temp folder hatte ich auch mal weil die die ganzen jet-brains-dinger
weil die haben das feature auch ich müsste mal upgraden weil die haben das ja die haben
das feature auch ich hab jetzt hier nix auf dafür ich lasse mal kurz updaten in der
zwischenzeit doch die musik geht mir echt auf den sack was haben wir sonst noch hier
so hektisch alter ja ok
was für eine jet-brains-lizenz hast du trial ich resette einfach immer meine trial immer
trial resettet sind halt stehen geblieben brauchen wir nicht brauchen wir nicht ja
wenn localhistory nicht so viel müll produzieren würde dann wäre das tatsächlich eine gute
extension
ganze get extensions brauche ich nicht ganze get extensions brauche ich nicht weil ich
get zu 99 prozent nur kommando zeile mache bevor ich darum klicke dass ich irgendwas
adden will oder irgendwas comitten will da habe ich das cli dreimal gemacht
was ist der hauptunterschied zwischen der pro und der community bei pile charm
wahrscheinlich dass eine kostenlos ist eine kostbarst und bei dem einen bei dem einen
kriegst du wahrscheinlich support bei dem anderen nicht also richtig echten nicht über
irgendeine form würde ich jetzt mal so vermuten sagen die leute dann auch jit bucket anstatt
spit bucket wahrscheinlich jit jithub sagen die dann mark down ok das ist jetzt nichts
was macht das werbung für sich selbst schau i o integration in visual studio es gibt ja
echt alles
live server beste es gibt einen rest client für visual studio code ok
ja wie gesagt da habe ich tatsächlich hier den den post mal installiert hier aber auch
nicht ok
aber jetzt ist jetzt nichts super super tolles mehr dabei warum endest du in meiner eins
in die uhr weil ich so das mache halt das hat keinen tieferen sinn das hat wirklich
keinen tieferen sinn und ich kann keinem empfehlen damit anzufangen
habe ich chat was übersehen die musik ist wieder übelst hektisch na gar das lasse
jetzt speichern also ne das hatten wir schon so also was empfiehlt ein reddit wir wissen
ja auf reddit kann man sich prinzipiell verlassen
gerade wenn es um so kontroverse themen geht wie was ist die beste visual studio code extension
da ist reine bestimmt die beste hilfe überhaupt
ja cheat 95 das kann man tatsächlich machen ich hatte mal
nen vim mit glaube ich 35 oder so plugins und so lustig das war und so coole sache man
da machen konnte wenn vim zum starten fünf sekunden braucht
dann ist irgendwas falsch das war nicht so sinnvoll irgendwie
das haben wir schon bookmarks haben wir auch schon
bash beautify es gibt was was automatisch bash schöner formatiert
oh eine schlechte bewährung moment was möchte er uns sagen was schönes
also also das da ist deutlich schöner als das da wahrscheinlich möchte er uns sagen
dass das da schön ist weil ansonsten wäre das ja auch irgendwie ugly feier
das ist genauso wie dieses reverse in den script was letztens irgendwann auf discord
gepostet hat der der der quasi anscheinend links einzurücken
so auf linke seite rechts macht 12 monate hyper subscription hier
der einschleid angeschön ja da ist so gut da ist so gut alles dabei
was man schon angeguckt haben gd jz martin 13 monat jetzt geht es aber
hier jetzt kommen die long a long term subscript subscribers excellent also ich
glaube die besten sachen haben wir uns jetzt alle schon angeguckt da tauchen
jetzt jetzt so ein paar sachen live server ist tatsächlich eines der besten
plugins da tauchen jetzt immer wieder die gleichen sachen auf
momenten reload button warum brauche ich den reload button da oben ist das ist
das der der button wenn visual studio code mal wiederum spackt dass man den
drückt und dann läuft es wieder richtig ist eigentlich keine schlechte idee
das haben wir auch schon ausprobiert das war auch ganz gut das haben wir auch
drauf haben wir auch drauf und bei ich mir da noch unschlüssig bin ob ich
wirklich brauche ich habe es jetzt mal drauf gelassen
was sind dann text power tools
ohne dass man zu zu big brain da können wir noch mal mal nach ins nach installs
nach installs oder in trending trending was ist trending ok wenn sachen mit
183 downloads schon trend trenden dann ist glaube ich trending nicht so ganz zu
gebrauchen pretty xml ok es gibt eine sache die ist niemals hübsch
zwei sachen das ist xml und java und c++ drei sachen
also es gibt des des bei das beißt sich
was ist denn das
das ist monka tos also fliegt sich gleich aus oder so was
gleich gleich ploppt der b a weg oder so ich trau den alles zu ich trau den
alles zu sebaro bist du noch da ok was macht das
this extension ist rewrite all code moment was only support mac os und
mich auch das geht nicht unter linux
du need download den weifu konnte what the fuck ich installiere mir doch nicht
irgendwelche komischen overlays aus dubiosen quellen
ok also trending ist irgendwie nicht so sinnvoll extra weiß man sofort bescheid
ok ich glaube man muss trending durchgucken und dann die die viele
downloads haben das sind die wirklich beliebten weil ansonsten ich mein
ernsthaft da ist ja ist ja viele nischen kram auch dabei
sagen von denen ich im leben noch nichts gehört habe motoko language support
schön weiß ich mal dass die sprache existiert überhaupt ich glaube ich
glaube wir gehen mal lieber nach die müssten so was haben wie top installs im
letzten monat aber so was sinnvolles auf die idee ist microsoft noch nicht
gekommen so nach dem motto meistens installs im letzten monat gibt es bei
den addons eigentlich irgendeine form von überprüfung kann jeder rein stellen
was er will ich glaube du kannst reinstellen was du willst
hast du schon feil utils ich weiß nicht ob wir uns ob wir uns das schon
angeguckt haben wir uns vorher schon angeguckt ein anderes hat man uns vor
angeguckt braucht man das ich mein man hat eh laufen die maus in der hand für
den browser da kann man doch in der time mit der maus anlegen oder das sage ich
als linux cli man
hi max ich habe vor kurzem mal was zusammen geschrieben könnte spaßig
werden ok
5 tools no developer needs ok das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an
das haben wir ausprobiert das war der größte schwachsinn genau das ist das
passt in diese liste hier rein das haben wir ausprobiert das war richtiger
schwachsinn aber eine coole idee irgendwo ja aber total man konnte sich auch
brennen lassen und so was und klippi war auch am start genau ja das haben wir
angeguckt das letzte mal
oh
tap nein oh das das moment das haben wir uns das moment das hatte ich das
letzte mal sogar noch offen hier was war denn das noch mal
advanced ai based auto complete for all ach das das haben wir uns angeguckt das
hatten wir uns das letzte mal schon angeguckt und da war ich skeptisch ob
das nicht eher nervt als dass es was bringt auch wenn es irgendwie big brain
style ausgesehen hat da war ich mir nicht da war ich unschlüssig ob das ob
das eher nervt oder oder was bringt ja
ich mein was hat man davon also was was was genau macht das was macht das so
gut was hätte vom kopf gerissen ich meine also ich kann sich halt schlecht
vorstellen ich will jetzt nicht sagen dass es bescheuert weil bei dir
funktioniert das ja ich kann es mir halt nicht nicht wirklich gut vorstellen
dass das großartig was bringt ich war so was ist schon cool wenn es direkt die
die parameter expansion gedünster macht
vielleicht probiere ich das mal wieder aus wenn ich ein bisschen javascript
mache bis dann siebauer ja ich bin auch nicht
mal so lange da ne halb stund oder so ich glaube ich probiere das mal aus
support ich war welches front frontend framework oder in welchem umfeld
verwendest du das er weiß wo das so besonders was bringt
intensifies das müsste jetzt noch einer machen mit
fury wenn ich mal wieder view js zeug macht dann probiere ich das mal aus wenn
ich chat erinnert mich dran
terminal rock vor ein paar das hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen
ich mein in welchen zeiten leben wir dass wir ein browser laufen lassen um
den terminal zu haben schwarz schau mal in line parameters vor wie es code an
ach ja
das ist wirklich ganz praktisch
ach mist das kann nur javascript ich hätte gesagt gerade bei gerade wenn ich
mich wieder mit c++ rumquälen muss wäre das sehr praktisch aber da kann es das
leider nicht für aber das ist eine coole sache ich probiere das kap mal kurz aus
wenn man ein bisschen geht es auch mit in line javascript in html
ein moment wie ist das ding jetzt pap nähe ich glaube um pap komm ich in
nächster zeit wirklich gut drumherum
ich probiere das jetzt mal aus install ja install ok das deshalb macht das bei
npm install hat es halbe internet im hintergrund installiert wahrscheinlich
ok probieren wir das mal aus also gehen wir hier rein hier script
sagen wir es mal hier kann let a gleich links so und das heißt wenn ich jetzt
sagen array und dann was weiß ich hier irgendwie pusch moment macht das nicht
standardmäßig schon
aber das aber das machte standardmäßig nicht dass es da bleibt ne
ich muss das mal kurz vergleichen mit dem mit dem default
das kann mit dem default vergleichen doch ach aber meinen eigenen sachen also
was wir hier keine ahnung keck und weh und dann sage ich hier name aber das
macht es doch standardmäßig auch schon oder verstehe ich jetzt bloß net ich
meine ich habe es jetzt nicht installiert und was was macht das denn
ach ok das muss dokumentiert sein verstehe also wenn ich das nicht
beschrieben habe dann steht auch nichts da
parameter annotations das zeigt nicht die parameter an das zeigt die die docs
dazu an ach so aber das hier müsste doch eigentlich auch docs haben oder hat es
keine docs new array of element aber ich habe es jetzt doch nicht installiert
ach das hier ach jetzt habe ich es kapiert das zeigt hier drinnen dann an
wo ich gerade bin ok da müssen wir was anderes nehmen also irgendwie keine
ahnung konkret oder so oder irgendwie
das zeigt in la ach jetzt jetzt weiß ich auch welches feature von den jet
prance dingern dass das nachbaut dass du in der funktions aufruf und also nicht
das pop-up sondern dieses graue hier das da also ich mache jetzt meine eigene
funktion also wir haben parameter keck weh und lull weh was falsch rum ist
sondern weil das weiß ja jeder dass lull weh größer keck weh ist und an i b n
so auch keine ahnung so und jetzt sage ich nehmen
und jetzt
das ist jetzt nicht anzeigen oder muss das noch konfigurieren
normalerweise jetzt erwartet dass hier drinne steht ok das heißt muss ich jetzt
mal ok das heißt ich mache jetzt 1 2 3 und dann schreibt das rein
was wie füllt die parameter was sowas hier so die default oder was oder
wir machen mal ein gs file auf ja das kann sein dass das nicht nicht mag ok
blub punkt gs also ok probieren wir noch mal
ok machen wir noch mal function ich kopiere mir den kram einfach
ich muss bestimmt neu starten ich muss bestimmt neu starten so das ist
immer kaputt oder muss man das irgendwie konfigurieren
doch die extension ist installiert
ich muss fünf parametern ich mache mal die hinteren weg
nee eigentlich nicht normalerweise sollte es also in intelli also in rider oder so ist
das dann immer so wenn man das eingeblend hat das steht dann hier drinne hier unten
dann also sprich wenn ich jetzt was eingibt dann steht dann davor quasi was
es ist dass das parameter lohnt ist und das parameter keck weh muss man vielleicht
dass irgendwie weiß nicht wie man java script docks macht viel zu kompliziert
ja wahrscheinlich ist das nicht so kompliziert gedacht und wie ist dieses
ding noch mal
moment inline parameters ja und da gibt es nichts einzustellen
dann weiß ich auch nicht dann fällt man zwar aber das ist eine gute das ist
eigentlich ein ziemlich gutes plugin tut es gerade nicht oder ich bin zu dumm
für es kann ja nicht auszuschließen language support java script ja haben wir
doch
ja guckt dass das das das das das das edit sofort hinten dran also sprich
selbst wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwie sowas hier nehme oder halt irgendwas da
müsst jetzt ah jetzt geht's wort warum geht es jetzt auf einmal what the fuck
oh es ist verbackt leute es ist kaputt ich habe es kaputt gemacht
oh ich habe es kaputt gemacht aber es ist wieder weg
ok vielleicht vielleicht doch keine default parameter aus wie hier 1 1 2
ok das mag er nicht aber aber hier funktioniert es tatsächlich schon mal
für ja da funktioniert komisch das feilspeicher ich laufen also da
funktioniert es aber bei den bei den eigenen funktionen funktioniert nicht
vielleicht mag er das auch so nicht kann aber an sich eine coole sache auch wenn
ich das ist das ist broken guck mal das ist total kaputt
mach mal js talks dazu was ich will das funktioniert hier docks et nee ich hab
keine ahnung wie das funktioniert lull ging das so
nee ich weiß nicht ich dokumentiere doch das nicht das wo ich weiß nicht wie
das geht vielleicht muss man diese extension mit
der reload extension kombinieren das wird sein endlich mal sind für den
reload button hallo erst mal wieder weg die laut exzellent so
feil und hilf sein das glaube ich auch nicht dass man das wirklich braucht so
was wird denn hier noch was wird denn hier noch hoch gehandelt bei microsoft
wir müssen jetzt leider die install gibt es wie es kohlt top installs last
month oder irgendwie sowas
hallo ich will ich kann nicht richtig schreiben wenn es zu spät
nicht gibt es anscheinend keine übersicht na gut wenn microsoft die
statistik nicht rausrückt da die bagger für java oje
noch mehr die bagger für chrome das habe ich mal verwendet ich weiß nicht
mal was mit der stadt angestört hat irgendwas hat mich daran gestört ich
krieg es aber nicht mehr zusammen hat mich voll gestört daran hat beautify
noch eine daseinsberechtigung weiß ich ich ich verwende nur das standard
formatting zeugs ich hatte noch nie in custom regel für
irgendwelche formatter formatter einzig was ich mal einstelle ist format und
safe bei allem wann kommt ein 5 plus plus ein stopp wischl ist gut was top
wischl studio count extent ticktock gerade ticktock ja weil ich auch so
aktiv auf ticktock bin project manager java pfp intellisens es wird immer
schlimmer hat er eine tolle tolle bewertung pfp intellisens
top top bewertung was ist eine gute pfp idee
also nicht dass ich pfp programmieren will aber webstorm taugt webstorm für pfp
mal ins gepäts torm die haben ja mittlerweile echt für alles was
ja pass intellisens das war nice installier ich jetzt auf haltschneid
installierter das haben wir uns anguckt das war wirklich sehr praktisch ja da
konnte man nämlich so dinge machen wie keine ahnung hier sagen wir mal include
in einem html link dann konnte man hier so sagen wobei das ging glaube ich
normalerweise auch schon an der stelle aber an anderen stellen ging es glaube
nicht
irgendwie so ich weiß nicht mehr es hat auf jeden fall dafür gesorgt dass man
an mehreren stellen pass completion machen kann das war äußerst praktisch
net be gibt es das noch ich habe net beans mafoi jahren verwendet für nicht
ja war auf jeden fall irgendwas mit in der extension ich weiß gar nicht mehr
für was
für d für c vielleicht ich könnte das für dass das rastplugin ganz gut war
ich weiß gar nicht mehr oder oder das pyson plugin ganz gut
irgendwas habe ich vor jahren verwendet seitdem nie wieder angeguckt
ok es kommt eben welche themes intellisens für css macht das denn
macht das das nicht standardmäßig schon ne das macht das nicht standardmäßig
schon aber wenn css im gleichen feil ist dann zeigt es das als normale completion
an welche idee nutzt du für pyson ich mach so gut wie kein pyson und wenn
würde ich wahrscheinlich auch wie es kommt verwenden einzige sprache wo ich
definitiv nicht wie es kommt verwendet ist verwenden würde ist dotnet c sharp
geht mittlerweile auch brauchbar aber ist kein vergleich zu visual studio oder
rider
ok die bewertungen sind geteilt fünf sterne einstern fünf sterne einstern
fünf sterne einstern
sagst wo wo wasted to our studios in say stupid stuff alles klar
irgendwie haben die ganzen topper extensions gar nicht so gute bewährungen
ja peitscharm ist mit sicher das ganze das ganze mit der begangenen bei dem
ganzen chat brains zeugs kann man nicht allzu viel verkehrt machen
wobei ich hier sagen muss also sie leihen hat mich jetzt noch nicht
überzeugen können das liegt aber wahrscheinlich auch
daran dass die integration mit meinem sp 32 2 nicht so gut funktioniert was ist
intellisens das ist auto completion im also wenn dein editor sachen auto
vervollständigt ja zum beispiel das hier was du gerade siehst das ist
intellisens wenn jetzt das a punkt oder zeigt dir die methoden an die du anwenden
kannst also die auto auto vervollständigung auf deutsch und das
ganze heißt intellisens weil das von microsoft in visual studio mal so
genannt wurde und irgendwie macht da jeder mit also auto completion auto
vervollständigung intellisens ist alles der gleiche kram
dacht flatter ja gut die zwei werden ja wahrscheinlich
hauptsächlich zusammen installiert man ja auch an anzahlen ja ich weiß noch
damals als ich angefangen habe ich sogar mal eclips mit dem pyson plugin
verwendet kennt das noch jemand das war absolute zumutung und dann gab es noch
irgend so eclips fork für für java script wie ist das denn altana ide oder
wie ist das alter altiner irgendwas mit a und ide oder so im namen das war dann
für php und und javascript und so übelster eclipse rotz einfach also da
erinnere ich mich echt nicht gerne dran atari nein nein atari ist das nicht
garantiert nicht wie ist das altana oder so
das hatte ich dann auch mal ganz früher für php willhelm kramer lp ne mit im
klammer ja ne dann weiß ich weiß ich mal wieder kram
hieß aber auch eclips müll eclips ist zumutung ich kann bis heute nicht
verstehen es leuchtet mir wirklich absolut nicht ein warum auf der arbeit
die entwickler teilweise so sehr auf eclips stehen ich meine es ist java ja
aber auch für java gibt es mit sicherheit deutlich bessere sachen
eclips hat man so vor zehn jahren mal verwendet
für java benutzt man intelli ja würde ich auch machen also wenn ich wirklich
java programmieren muss dann würde ich mit intelli ja machen ja
ich meine nicht intellisens sondern das hier
was zum moment was intelli fans das ist einfach nur jemand der lustig sein
wollte bei seiner extension php code intelligence wird das ist php auch für
vollständigung wahrscheinlich weil sie elefant ist
die sonst sind da irgendwie keine großartigen excel viewer geilen sachen
mehr dabei was sagt denn reddit reddit verlass verlass uns nicht okay das war
es was haben die hier bracket per color also das haben ja das empfehlen sie
alle irgendwie
ja beste in so datestaffe gibt es eine extension ich mache ich gebe einfach
date ein und copy paste das
irgendwie ist da nichts dabei was sie jetzt noch anbieten ich glaube die
besten sachen haben wir wirklich jetzt schon in erfahrung gebracht
weiß nicht ob ihr noch irgendwelche geheimtipps habt wie gesagt mal so die
die eigentlichen language extensions mal außen vor ich meine mir ist klar dass
man eine python extension installieren sollte wenn man eine python programmiert
oder ruby wenn man ruby was gibt es eigentlich für ruby extensions gibt es
gescheite muss ich mal kurz gucken ruby ruby ja vom pang
ich halte ein paar ganz gute zu geben
essentials pack was ist denn im essentials pack
default dark plus was was macht das language mit ach so das ist ein bisschen
abgecreatedes default themen ok und warum also wie wäre es wie wäre es wenn man
da jetzt mal reinschreibt was man geändert hat
aber kein bock
ja das haben wir jetzt im größten toll schon ich glaube wir haben ja unter
weniger alle guten sachen entdeckt
color manager was macht das denn vm was ist denn heute los
sneaky boy fragt ich habe in meinem netzwerk jetzt ein pie hole next cloud
und plex auch ein plex user das ist auch so ein ding wo ich noch kein
anwendungs wofür das wird jetzt mal ernsthafte frage wird mich wirklich
interessiert wofür verwendest du plex ich sehe da ich sehe da zwei
anwendungszwecke oder so immer die anwendungszwecke den ich sehe ist wenn
man massig illegales zeug runtergeladen hat dass man gerne mehr als einmal
angucken will ansonsten wüsste ich nicht wofür man plex braucht genau das ist
ein anwendungsfall ok dann verstehe ich auch warum ich kein plex brauche weil
ich habe mittlerweile nicht mehr massig runtergeladenes illegales zeugs und ich
habe mittlerweile auch wenig sachen die ich doppelt angucken will schon
pracet ja den habe installiert den pracet per color eiser du kannst auch
legal deine blu rays rippen die frage ist nur warum wie gesagt die meisten
sachen gucke ich mir einmalig an und gut ist es gibt ganz wenige sachen so
sachen wie matrix oder so habe ich ein paar mal geguckt aber das meiste
nicht
ja was machen in der color manager
ach guck mal der hat so ein color picker der color picker ist aber bestimmt nicht
irgendwie jetzt macht das denn am moment es ist mein mein visual studio themen
oder ist das für ist es jetzt moment ist es für eine webseite oder ist es jetzt
für visual studio code selbst das ist ach so man kann jetzt eine farbe auswählen
dem ding eine name geben und dann kann man das später wieder hinzufügen oder
sowas ok das ist nicht schlecht also wenn man viel css styling kram macht ist das
glaube ich ziemlich praktisch aber ich mache nicht viel css styling kram
erscheint nicht übel zu sein wenn man das wenn man das wenn man so dinger
macht
ach so ja sneaky boy also die frage war ja ich habe in meinem netzwerk jetzt ein
pie hole nex cloud und plex hat immer noch vorschläge was ich mal ausprobieren
sollte du könntest
jetzt was ich wollte sagen du könntest falls du den fritz phone hast kannst du
wir haben wir haben nämlich noch zwei olle deckt fritz phones da habe ich noch
was laufen was was die kontakte aus nextcloud fritz phone züngt ja gut
in den fileserver kannst du machen denn ich habe noch einen doku wiki laufen
weil ich immer noch weil ich ehrlich gesagt immer noch doku wiki am
praktischsten finde wenn du gibt sachen eigene projekte intern bei dir
hosten willst würde ich dir das da empfehlen es ist auch ganz nützlich das
ist quasi mehr oder weniger github nur intern zum selbst hosten ansonsten fällt
mir da als erstes mal nicht so viel ein wenn du unify access points hast in
unify manager server wie das ding genau heißt
bunte klammern ja bunte klammern haben wir auch das ist in der tat eines der
besten extensions die man bisher gefunden habe ich das wieder gelöscht
warum geht es denn nicht warum kalle reister die brackets nicht was ist da
los warum wenn die brackets nicht kalle reist warum was ist hier los
der bracket kalle reiser ist kaputt ah jetzt geht er wieder exzellent broken
22 uhr was polar code nutzt du open wrt ich habe mit mikrotik router wenn ich
bisschen abgedrehtere sachen machen will das bräuchte ich ach das ist da wo man
screenshots von machen kann ja das das habe ich schon gesehen
das habe ich auch kein anwendungszweck für job limit was für sing immer next
laut gerade auch wenn ich next laut schon seit ewigkeiten los werden will
regex reviewer eide hier jetzt haut er die extensions raus hier
ach so was ich habe das im wimm dass man gehighlighted bekommt was
search und replace regex das search und replaceen würden das ist ganz
nützlich ansonsten das brauche ich ehrlich gesagt nicht in meiner ide drin
oder besser gesagt in meinem editor drin
hast du mittlerweile eine gute self-hosted online collaboration software gefunden
sowas wie next lauter mitbringt und alternative zu ne gucke ich auch nicht
danach weil ich nicht collaborate will mit leuten online ne habe ich nicht gibt
es bettter twitch tv emotes in visual studio code ja das wäre tatsächlich
mal wichtig wie es code twitch chat exzellent da sind wir doch schon mal dabei
big brain extension da kann man programmieren und twitch chat gucken
der cute chat ist immer dabei ok brauchen tut es ja nur wirklich niemand
aber die idee ist schon cool das ist das ist wenn man wenn man streamt dann kann
man das quasi als overlay haben oder so man brauchen twitch account log in kann
man nicht einfach so oft machen
das geht für den eigenen chat anscheinend klar kann man kann man das
brauche brauchen uns wirklich niemand aber ich finde ich finde schon mal cool
dass die meisten sachen wo man so auf die idee kommt sich so denkt wie sieht es
denn damit aus die gibt es schon die hat schon irgendjemand gemacht
ich glaube jetzt haben wir so ziemlich alles durch alle gescheiten allgemein
kündigen kündigen share your regex online
das ist für alle big brain regex hexer hexer heckermans ruby hat eh die
abgedrehteste regex engine ruby regex ist sowas wie c++ templates
es hat mal irgendeiner mathematisch nachgewiesen dass ruby regex sündtags
touring complete ist also sprich dass du in ruby regex sündtags jedes
erdenkliche programm machen kann auch wenn es also berechnen kann es nicht
jedes erdenkliche programm machen kannst dass du alles berechnen kannst was was
es gibt in ruby regex es hat mal einer ein
decimal binary converter in ruby regex programmiert
weiß ich ob das jetzt findet aber irgendeiner hat einen wie gesagt
einen binary dezimal oder sowas converter in ruby regex programmiert
das war auch ganz abgedreht so 22 ich muss jetzt wirklich ich muss jetzt
eigentlich offen morgen muss ich arbeiten
eigentlich will ich noch nicht oft bis auf bis auf kaum on oder wie lang war ich
jetzt und hier guck mal 2 1 2 stunden es geht weil er spontane aktion
max morgen 18 uhr in video stream ja darf man das stream haben die da schon
irgendwas zu gesagt nicht dass sie den apple machen aber wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich strebt das eh jeder also gerüchten zu folgen ist es ja so dass
es irgendwie 3080 gibt ti oder so oder 3090 also sprich das ist jetzt dass die
3090 wohl noch eins stärker als die 3 30 80 ti oder irgendwie sowas ist
irgendwie so
stromverbrauch ist ist heftig also weil es sollte es nämlich wirklich so sein
dass die 3090 so die die top karte ist am anfang und dann auch bleiben wird dann
ist das natürlich noch mal geil dann gebe ich dann gebe ich dann auch dann
gebe ich dann 2k für die grafikkarte aus oder so die zu teuer eigentlich
braucht jetzt dann braucht jetzt vier slots oder so
vier pci slots oder was brauche die jetzt die wann ist das morgen
18 uhr
wobei ich glaube das habe ich mir sogar schon mal aufgeschrieben ja 18 uhr
exzellent soll vielleicht einmal reingucken
ja das gucken wir uns morgen an ich denke mal man kann da streamen weil nvidia
ist ja marketing technisch nicht blöd
die streams und sonst was ist ja letztendlich kostenlos gefundenes fressen
so können wir notification machen ja tatsächlich mal gucken was die dinger an strom brauchen
na gut ich gehe jetzt auf leute chat bis morgen macht's gut zu